tossing the street at you but is the
scariest thing I've ever done
[Music]
slowing down I will kill you get out
if you go to Cuba you visit the popular
waterfront promenade it's featured in
movies countless stories about Cuba I
went there it was fascinating your thing
on our program and also Santos Unidos
not to me los Estados Unidos
yo tengo una programa en los estados
unidos Commedia
so many men in Cuba have beards that
they're shavings literally cover the
surface of the ocean say gusta la gente
de Cuba este programa as possibly oh
they like it oh good good bueno you're
sewing we Polydor okay baby
Oh rum that's rum thanks good run huh
good
[Music]
I know one that's good bueno
yes suitably well the only kill me Rudy
Rudy give me rum in a box get better
than this
muchas gracias Rudy Fantastico what's
that Oh fubá no - now it's probably not
a wagon
well Rudy here just cost me every
sponsor I have collected welcome my new
sponsor Ron Kuby
that's around the inner box
[Applause]
you